uh hi there steve kaufman here again
um i am going to continue in my series
on how i learn different languages and i
i think the order is going to be uh i
can't remember but i think it might be
italian
portuguese
russian
i might sneak korean in there
and then
check
but today i'm going to interrupt this
series and i'm going to talk about a
different subject because it's something
that's kind of been on my mind today
and that is you know learning the basics
in a language
and we often hear that it's so important
to nail down the basics to get the
pronunciation right
to learn the basic phrases the basic
structures the basic vocabulary
in a language
and
i am totally opposed to that idea
i think it's and from a number of points
of view and i'm going to ramble on i
haven't made little notes here but i'm
just going to share my thoughts on the
subject and i look forward to hearing
back from people
on it but
first of all i find it very difficult to
learn the basics
uh if i look at czech you know some of
the most basic
phrasing around i like
uh you know mom rod yeah mamrad simam
raad i mean
i like it pretty basic
it's very hard to get a hang of
or to get the hang up it's very hard to
to get the feel of that to make it feel
natural it's only after now
almost five months of listening to a
variety of content that i go back and i
review some of those uh
basic phrases again
and and they're starting to sink in it's
the same with basic vocabulary like
you know very often people will try to
teach you the colors the days of the
week the months of the year the numbers
these things are all considered basic
those are extremely hard to learn
numbers being by far the most difficult
i can be quite advanced in a language
and it's not for lack of trying you know
you try to learn those things they just
don't stick basic vocabulary again
people say well if you learn the most
common a thousand words that'll be 70 80
of of any context yeah but it won't be
the key words and and if you're into
interesting content anyway all of those
words are going to be there so my
approach is
what i would call almost a grazing
approach like you go over the same
ground
from many different directions maybe
using different materials different
stories you sometimes do difficult
things you want to get ahead you want to
challenge yourself
because you find it interesting
when i start in a language i'm mostly
motivated to build up my vocabulary and
expose myself to the language
um
so once i have a bit of a sense of the
language
then i can go back and and try to again
look at some of these so-called basic
structures and i'll have a reference
point
i think our whole approach to language
learning and to education in general is
far too lineal you know typically in
school in a language classroom the
teacher will tell you you can only read
this far in the book you can't go any
further i mean that's ridiculous why
wouldn't you allow
students to go further why wouldn't you
allow people to follow their interests
and go well beyond the level where the
classroom is and to come back and then
do something that's well below
the level where the classroom is why do
you always have to stay at the same
level that's dictated by the teacher and
i don't think that just is limited to
language learning i think in many
subjects why do we have schools where
everything is divided into 30 or 40
minutes segments and every 30 or 40
minutes you've got to go do and you got
to go and do something else why don't
you let people really focus on one area
that they're interested in and take it
whichever direction they want and then
come back maybe do some of the simple
stuff again in other words the whole
learning process should be much more
sort of um how would i put it organic
grazing swarming not linear not now i've
got these basic concepts down now i'll
move to the next because you don't
really get those basic concepts down
until very often much much later and so
you're filling in sometimes with some
advanced concepts or some advanced
technology or at least vocabulary that
you happen to remember
and some of the most supposedly basic
uh vocabulary items are still escape you
and they kind of fill in later it's not
it's not a linear process
so i often you know hear this about
learn the basics get the basics the
basics
come
when the whole
has been
absorbed and the brain has become more
familiar with with this holistic thing
called the language and slowly some of
the so-called basics start to solidify
simply because that you've been exposed
to them so often
and i remember again the words of
manfred spitzer that the brain requires
novelty and repetition in order to learn
something if you don't have novelty if
you don't feed the interest that that we
have in a subject then we get turned off
but we do need to repeat we do need to
cover the same ground again and again in
order that these neurons can can can
fire
so repetition is important
but i think we should allow much more
freedom to to students to explore and to
push as far as they want to push
and then have them come back and review
again
so i'm not a big fan of of the basics
i'm not a big fan of a linear approach
to education
the basic building blocks
um
as you know i'm not a big fan of getting
people to speak early so nailing down
the phonetics in you know phase one of
your studies to me is not important if
you're doing a lot of listening you can
get a lot of exposure without having to
produce the sounds so that when you do
start to produce the sounds you'll have
a better feel for the language
so yeah i just thought i'd throw that in
there
avoid trying to learn the basics it's
too difficult
rather explore the language
explore it in the directions that you
want to take it
but
you know try to cover the same ground
from different directions
in different contexts so it's
i
personally prefer more of a generalized
grazing
approach
as opposed to some kind of a linear
structured approach approach to learning
and it's true history you know i can
read a history book i don't remember
much but if i read a history i'm reading
a history of russia or of napoleon if i
read three different books or if
napoleon comes up again in my history of
russia and there's more places where all
of these different things
interconnect
than this overlapping exposure is what
is what's eventually going to enable me
to learn the subject so that it starts
to be natural and it starts to be real
knowledge to me
the linear approach may be good for
passing an exam you know cramming a
bunch of facts in your head for the exam
but in terms of acquiring general
knowledge i think it's less useful and
that and i do believe that it applies to
to language learning so that was a bit
of a digression from my uh tales of how
i went about learning different
languages so thank you for listening and
i look forward to your comments